m
à niort le 20 décembre dernier océane a
démenti du haut de ses 10 ans créé la
surprise en remportant le titre de vice
championne de france de squash dans sa
catégorie fille de moins de 11 ans avec
des garçons selphy
et pas juste un seul à avoir une
médaille je peux me donner à fond pour
réussir que je peux continuer
faire mieux
une fois j'ai progressé
j'améliore
hop bonjour
continuez il y a encore quatre ans
océane ne connaissait rien du squash
elle découvre alors ce sport lors
d'actions de découverte gratuites mises
en place par l'association fctr squash
pendant le temps scolaire et en péri et
extra scolaire dans les écoles du
quartier de la ravine blanche la ligue
depuis quatre ans en fait elle a un
projet associatif est axée sur le
développement proche du particulièrement
auprès des jeunes
donc on a des actions gratuites pour les
jeunes qui sont mis en place dans tous
les quartiers et là avec les actions du
contrat de ville pendant les combats
quartiers prioritaires
fait donc découvrir le squash français
yann elle a commencé le squash avait
découvert le squash de ses 300 l'a
licencié pour sa troisième saison
sportive oceane bénéficie quatre fois
par semaine de l'entraînement de jean
christophe sarrio responsable sportif de
la sttr squash au stade volnay à
saint-pierre classé 25e au même
championnat l'an dernier cette médaille
d'argent a été une véritable surprise
pour l'entraîneur cette année là donc le
titre de vice-championne de france pour
océane ab monty est une surprise parce
que je ne connaissais pas forcément
toutes les participantes aux
championnats de france
c'est la deuxième année seulement que
l'on participe avec océane et donc
j'avais pas la qualité des autres
joueuses en tête
donc effectivement elle a fait un
parcours remarquable elle a éliminé la
tête de série 2
en quarts de finale donc ça ça a été la
plus grosse surprise ce qui lui a permit
derrière d'avoir un tableau un petit peu
plus facile en demi-finale et d'arabes
et d'accéder à la finale assez
facilement
la réunion a depuis toujours former des
champions de france à l'exemple de
thierry lincou champion du monde en 2004
grâce à l'aide de la mairie ainsi que
des collectivités les jeunes réunionnais
découvre ce sport passionnant et
conquiert les plus hautes marches des
podiums dans le squash mondiale le
départ pour le sport c'est aussi
l'éducation c'est la santé et
accompagner les clubs qui oeuvrent
surtout au fola dans la proximité c'est
quelque chose d'important plan et
particulièrement pour la ftf quoi on a
eu un accompagnement constant à
plusieurs niveaux tant qu'il ya
l'accompagnement au niveau de la ville
et aussi l'accompagnement au niveau du
conseil départemental
il accompagne les projets qui accompagne
si le fonctionnement des clubs et nous
on a agi sur ces deux niveaux là et on
accompagne aussi les projets et les
sportifs de haut niveau donc notre part
sur la réussite des sportifs rayons
particulièrement au squash a été
constant océane fait aujourd'hui la
fierté de toute sa famille qui
continuera à la suivre et l'encouragé
dans ce sport qu'il épanoui je sois
jeune apporter beaucoup d'épanouissement
c1
familial de pur scolaires aussi salek
beaucoup et je dis bah il faut continuer
dans ce sens donc les jeunes les gones
et surtout et les étoiles et viennent
faire le squash fait quelque chose de
bien
je suis convaincu que ces rachats
suspens
ma part je suis fier de ma petite nièce
mais c'est une très belle réussite